I am absolutely 100% fluent in Tagalog
after just one week
And that`s no lie.
Well... actually, it is.
But... you know...
Hi guys, this is Paul
Last week I posted a video telling you
about my intention to study Tagalog.
And the question is: "did I actually follow through?"
Did I actually study it and
follow the plan I had told you about?
Or did I sit around watching tv and drinking some Coke
and eating chips and whatever, instead of studying?
That's the question.
So I'd like to show you a bit of my week.
What I did, and then show you the end result,
which is some of what I learned during that week.
So, have a look and see what you think.
Hindi. Hindi ako nakakaintindi ng Tagalog.
Angaling mo mag Tagalog.
Tagalog Ang pronouns and Ng pronouns
Tagalog question words
Hindi akong masyadong mabuti.
Paki sulat mo
"Please write that"
"Could you write that? Yeah.
Mamaya. That means "later".
Hindi ako gutom.
Mali mali akong magtagalog.
Pero nakakaintindi ako kaunti. NG kaunti.
Making Anki flashcards.
Puede bang magtanong?
Tubig ang gusto kong inumin.
Ako rin. Kain tayo mamaya.
Alright... Magandang tanghali, lahat!
(Good evening, everyone)
Ang pangalan ko ay Paul.
(My name is Paul)
Nagagalak akong makilala kayo.
(I am pleased to meet you)
Patawad dahil hindi ako masyadong marunong magtagalog.
(I'm sorry I can't speak much Tagalog)
Pero nakakaintindi ako ng kaunti.
(But I understand a little)
Isang linggo pa lang akong nag-aaral ng Tagalog.
(I've been studying Tagalog for only 1 week)
Nag-aaral ako ng Tagalog dahil madalas
akong pumupunta sa Pilipinas.
(I'm studying Tagalog because I often go to Philippines)
Isa akong Kanadian, pero nasa Hapon ako ngayon.
(I'm Canadian but, right now, I'm in Japan)
Nagtuturo ako ng inlges sa mga Hapones sa unibersidad.
(I teach English to Japanese people at an University)
At gusto ko ang trabaho ko sa unibersidad.
(And I like my job at the University)
Gusto kong mag-aral ng iba't ibang lingwahe,
(I like studying foreign languages)
at gusto kong maglakbay.
(And I like travelling)
At gusto ko rin magbasa ng libro,
(And I also like reading books)
at magaral ng marami.
(And learning a lot)
At ngayon gusto kong gumawa ng bideyo para sa Youtube,
(And now I like making videos for Youtube)
at sumulat ng blog.
(And i write a blog)
At sa libre kong oras,
(And, in my free time,)
gusto ko ring maglakwatsya kasama ang kaibigan ko.
( I like to hang out with my friends. )
Hindi ako nayayamot, dahil marami akong ginagawa!
(I don't get bored, because I do a lot of things.)
Ok,... Magandang araw sa iyo! ... Bye.
(Have a good day)
Obviously I have a long way to go.
But I think I got off to a good start in my first week.
If you love languages, don't forget to subscribe.
Studying Tagalog is awesome, by the way!